[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et à chacun
alors je vais commencer ce partage avec
une petite histoire j'ai vécu il fallait
rencontre est une magnifique jeune fille
elle
s'est en sorti d'une conférence et
m'accrocher et m'a demandé des conseils
je lui dis parfois hématies malgré ses
revenus alors que marianne qu'elle avait
besoin
je vis d'accord alors qu'on pouvait
changer ma donné la raison de sa demande
elle m'a dit qu'elle était désolée obs
qui sont même ouverts chaque fois
qu'elle parle des sujets sociaux
d'accomplissement parce que lorsqu'on le
parcours est
les dijon conjuguée au genou de richie
mccaw déconseillé
aux sorties de cela les avait pas
pourquoi suis venu parce qu'elle allait
cher au final parce que ce qui était le
meilleur en cause de terrain gelé jours
donc même pas quels conseils suivis
comme j'étais la boutique mois le
nouveau né je vis maintenant conscience
des hommes je parle pas assez du temps
de changer les mots et en images
commençons par les jeux mis à part agir
et lui avait dit c'est la non danse que
je vais te pares ajoute martin et moi je
ne sais pas quels conseils pour être
dans
et en partageant l'expérience
avec elle j'ai compris j'ai réalisé
beaucoup de choses
je les dis que pour commencer une route
des maris et surtout dans le processus
de création d'une entreprise
il est grand temps
de commencer avec ce corner et avec ce
courage
et je le dit trois choses moi aidez moi
aussi trois choses continuent de payer
et quand j'entends que l'usiné qui
montrent que j'ai réalisé les derniers
avant que cette chose là naît dans le
quotidien de mes activités
[Musique]
ça va se réinventer ce thème même si
beaucoup de choses mais si je veux la
d'appellation jeune fille dans chacune
de mes entreprises
ce qui nous est là aussi ce qui nous
intéresse ici est en nous amanda
cheesley
fière de compter sur d'autres os
d'extérieur il faudra compter avec ce qu
on est irresponsable et je me dis
qu'aujourd'hui je réalise que trois
choses et tant que je n'aurai pas aller
aussi à ce soit moi était et continue de
prêter ses trois chansons llorente son
plaisir parce que
beaucoup de ceux qui m'ont précédé on en
parlait llorenti la détermination et la
russie bien si
je lui ai dit c'est important d'arrêter
pas là de voler des photos nettes quand
tu commences soit on aime qu'on va toi
même
son temps des barrages je peux réaliser
que ferait de ce passionné de grougi
passionnés de communication sont
passionnés de décès mais ce que je sache
ça peut-être que j'ai vu ça m'a plu
j'aimerais faire
jérôme
[Musique]
charlebois est ce que ça fait qu'est ce
que je voyais mon courage et
l'honnêteté est cette chose qui nous
permet de vous montrer que nous sommes
véritablement ce que l'on partage
d'expériences leurs idées telles choses
qui te fait deja de 10 j'ai bossé avec
ses concerts à l'o2 ce n'est pas le
temps
leur est compté quelque chose qui te
guidera de 10 de ces partis de rien
avant que ce n'est pas la
personne humaine et aurait commencé à
long de ces vagues
non moi
c'est pas que j'aime le 28 mai
alan desousa le calme et mourut me dites
pas remonter
je suis pour la suppression j'ai
commencé à laisser au fond parce
qu'effectivement les activités
ont redémarré avec le pam a besoin
d'argent mais les passions j'ai commencé
à partir de riz moi ça me gêne pas ce
que tu es dans la société que tu
proposes à partir de l'espagne que tu
dis ça suffit les réseaux sociaux
l'islam
parce que
la jonquera que jamais le jour même
genre a même commencé à vue pour une
chance avec ton énergie avec passion
avec des règles et ces choses là son
principal
il ne faut pas la négliger faune en
notre compagnie il ya une fois en maître
de le dire comme ça rires
le renier intelligent et c'est ce qui
fait que souvent ce qui veut acquérir ou
entamer un processus de création
d'entreprise ont un peu perdu
mais bon là j'ai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je met aussi le doigt on va pas pris
selon des témoins personnellement ça m'a
planté quel est le son grand lévis
souvent conseil conseille pas de
compenser
mon action aujourd'hui nous axons dies
ou si en plus elle sous le feu des
projecteurs
pourquoi je vous trouve un détachement
les parents fratrie quelque chose de là
bas tu m'as pas une hornet qui tue en
est aujourd'hui 3 2 mais quand tu seras
avec des frais de certains tu parles pas
les mots
aux
salariés d'avoir des stratégies de
marketing comme outil
de partage son expérience qui
franchirait tirage limité
forme du moment elles donneront deux ont
redit que l'histoire n'est pas
extraordinaire
la pression n'a pas fait son père et sa
mère la raison il ya des choses qu'on
fait du sahel je ne mens pas de plumer
obligé de s'approprier l'histoire
l'expérience de gagner dont on parle pas
besoin d'avoir une grande
forme histoire quelque part c'est ton
histoire et place aux jeux de la machine
et cette droite là il ya des personnes
qui sont dit-on est familier mais cette
version de l'année
c'est fascinant de la réflexion mais pas
reçu de l'argent de même parmi ceux là
on m'a dit vous êtes passionné par une
guérite on peut le dire aujourd'hui ce
sont l'histoire et c'est comme ça qu'est
la russie
la deuxième chose que j'aimerais
partager qui est aussi dépendante et la
détermination
et je ne suis pas là pour définissez le
trois roues mais juste pour montrer
combien de temps
on peut peut-être monty qui promet
d'être passionnant et qui charrie
beaucoup de chemin
comme savent il nous faut pas aussi
vindicatif par aussi sa venue au dos du
cheval
m'émouvoir c'est la détermination qui
fera aller plus l'eau c'est la vie d'amy
nations qui nous permet de ne pas perdu
vos objectifs transparents et russes a
rapporté et si ça quand tu ne m'as menti
parce que l'entrepreneuriat chez panisse
au désamarrage pasqua ne s'est pas
fatigué qui a fasciné c'est du passé
c'est humain taux distincts pas facile
facile et aux portes se ferment et léger
mais c'est quand on déterminer quand tu
vois quand une détermination totale à
son sein en fait je sais même pas ce qui
peut dans la vie quant à moi je sais pas
je vois pas et quand je me lève à donner
je plus aujourd'hui pouvoir passer
détermination
je les ai vus a pas une chose c'est vers
la résilience ce magnifique mots qui me
met toujours en joie le jeu lorsque
j'entends quelques années de méfiance
s'étend aux magnifiques dans la forme
mais imaginez le fond imaginez une
personne 4 ha agitée de résilience cette
façon qu'elle capacité d'affronter
le chaos de sa vie où les difficultés
liées à ces nombreux prix à son travail
à sa vie de famille à sa vie quotidienne
chaque personne pas cette capacité
même temps et même appétit militante des
droits civiques
et
sinon au petit poucet
je la dis tu peux pas l'être déterminer
la capacité de résistance d'ubs a
redonné
tu vas pour donner mais ma part yves
[Musique]
ossonce avis tu vas te rôle du mari
réalisé avec ses amis
et je me dis à chaque fois sur
l'histoire jeu mais si la relation de
parent isolé selon une voisine ayant
chacun mais il est temps que tu toi dans
l'histoire
se réinventer tiens revenue aux basiques
pour moi ça me fait une petite souris
est monté c'est un mauvais ni à se
tourner réellement se montrer au grand
jour que nous semblent réellement en
aimant se réinventer cinéma comme rôles
froome et à quelqu'un d'autre
cette soigner et quand je la dis sur le
monde et j'aime réaliser de ce qui nous
aidera aussi est en nous d'abord
d'abord
parce qu'il faut que du personnel du
site de réunion des deux autos situation
complique les bonnes choses sans que la
personne
pour l'histoire partir de l'été tu dors
des ministres une fois que tu racontes
ya un coup de pied mal j'aime le toit
met en devoir apporter de secafi
pour pouvoir raconter mon histoire
avec une grande entreprise
quand je les dis
qu'à un taureau d'image surtout pour la
relation de la désinfection j'ai
expérimenté l'empathie envers lui l'en-v
raison parce que le concert ne me disait
pas de mini siècle heureusement le
comportant la fumée collection d'état
n'a
jamais misé sur la passion et du rêve et
natalité donc dans les collections de ne
pas du tout a été le congé des salines
projet une famille humaine ils ont tout
acheté qui donc je préfère la grosse
tétine
bassidji et non pas des mineurs
moi ils aller dynamo millions par année
dont j'ai été emmené dans le monde nous
dit c'est moi je ne veux m'acheter mon
agent que jour ça à ton version techno
jet je sois honnête et que j'ai fait de
voir de miser plus sur la qualité de mes
produits
de collection sont juste à pouvoir
monter les collections mon équipe de
moins à essayer d'aller mener envers mon
client quand c'est comme ça tu mama peur
même si jusqu'à aujourd'hui on a plaisir
à
détruire ma bien fait mais tu peux
marcher vers la chine en passant par
lourdes à une toiture attrapés
pour la résilience de la terminer par la
boule arrivants
j'aime bien et lui une faction que j'ai
lu pas parce que j'en ai peu de physique
en parler nous
voilà un auteur boris emilie qui disait
lundi que la rigueur c'est la de magique
et dans
si tu es tellement magnifique subtil
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui peut nous ébranler notre
et rêver comme le prélat dit qu'est ce
qui peut nous empêcher d'être réussi
simon s'est dit enfin le fait envahir
est ce que j'aimerais que vous retenez
de ce partage des points sourit porteurs
que sont les tétées la détermination et
la loge
ce qu'il faut travailler plus
il faut travailler manuellement
ne disons pas ne sont pas nourris
le mode et icifer une défense allemand
ça peut changer parcours
toi comment ça change et nous laisse du
reste
il faut travailler un élément dans la
détermination
s'emparer pas une détermination son mari
honda
je ne pensais pas le jeune albert
donc il faut travailler honnêtement avec
détermination sans faille
pour que même temps c'est du bon soyons
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]